let's be real even if you've managed to
get Oscar winners to don tights and
trade quips with space raccoons you're
bound to drop the ball every once in a
while
try not to cringe too hard as we dive
headfirst into the MCU zwarst casting
decisions ever Thor the dark world is
one of the most forgotten entries of the
MCU sure it's set up another infinity
stone and gave Jane Foster in the gang
something to do and brought Loki back
after of course seemingly killing him
off earlier in the same flick but that's
about it
it's just kind of there a huge part of
Dark Worlds failure to resonate was
Eccleston's limp portrayal of Malekith
Malekith a dark elf currently at the
center of Marvel's War of the realms
comic events it's a malevolent trickster
with a taste for wicked turn about sin
gleeful cruelty Eccleston's embodiment
reflects exactly none of this his aims
are vey something something returned the
universe to darkness yadda yadda the
rightful destiny of the Dark Elves
standard villain gobbledygook and his
personality is no better defined if you
remember anything it's his round eyed
mask and elaborately braided hair and
having your performance overshadowed by
the costuming Department is never what
an actor should aim for it's hard to
waste a smooth icy mass mickelson as a
villain from Casino Royale to Hannibal
he spent most of his career sending
chills down audience's spines and when
the story around him is well told and
acted that makes it a doubly impressive
feat to somehow bungle his character
solid writers story colleagues in
costuming plus the dude who played
lashya as the villain how could that
possibly go wrong
Doctor Strange showed us how despite the
fact that it's a dizzyingly shot
snappily written origin story and
despite how brilliant Benedict Wong and
Benedict Cumberbatch are on their
principal roles
Mickelson's casts ileus the magic user
who serves the fiendish Dormammu is
utterly forgettable like Malekith the
most memorable thing about his character
is the makeup wizardry performed upon
him to make it look as though his skin
is flaking away beneath his eyes
beyond that there
a few cool tricks he does with his magic
blades maybe a quip or two that landed
okay he is totally wasted in the role
and entirely overshadowed by the rest of
the marginally enjoyable movie at least
he's got the rest of his filmography to
fall back on
Mickey Rourke is definitely not
forgettable as Yvonne Vanko he gobbles
up scenery with a spoon letting the
light catch in his gold teeth whenever
he can
brandishing his Russian accent like a
sabre at every scene partner amen don't
get to a pitch to ping learn to live
good many entries on this list are here
because they are cinematic nonentities
entirely swallowed up in the shadows of
other actors special effects in the
ever-growing tower of MCU world building
that ain't the case here Iron Man 2 is
widely considered one of the lesser
Marvel movies but if you remember
anything about it you remember Eve on
Vanko but honestly is that really a good
thing
rorke is a bit too present in the role
as an actor he never disappears into the
character it's almost entertaining on
its own to watch Roark put so much
energy into Vanko but ultimately it
distracts from everything around it
years after the fact you don't recall
the family debts the character was
trying to repay you remember the accent
the teeth the bird the whips you
remember everything around the character
but not the character himself and in
movie terms that's an unforgivable flaw
quick remember everything you can about
Kristine Palmer if that name doesn't
ring a bell and it probably doesn't just
replace it with dr. Strange's girlfriend
okay you might reply she was a doctor
too and there's that one scene they have
in a closet together in the hospital and
you're pretty sure you remember the
actors from that notebook movie if you
did any better than that you should be
commended Kristine Palmer is effectively
a girlfriend shaped prompt but that
isn't exactly unique there are a lot of
forgettable girlfriend ex roles that
talented actresses make the best of but
some of them see Hayley Atwell as Peggy
Carter or Zoe Saldana's Gamora managed
to break out and become something more
McAdams christine Palmer just kind of
stands around like cassellius the
general psychedelia of the movie
surrounding her serves to overshadow her
completely and really that isn't
entirely a bad thing it's a pretty
incredible spectacle after all still we
get the feeling that even the time stone
wouldn't be able to bring McAdams
unmemorable
formitz back from the dead some things
just can't be fixed if there was ever a
moment Ironfist seemed like a good idea
no one remembers it now that it's been
officially canceled the cultural autopsy
can be performed and by far the biggest
problem is Finn don't we perform insane
ear and is let's face it reality
shatteringly annoying and he never quite
stops being so he's a young billionaire
searching for himself and yet somehow
he's even more irritating than that
description implies his quest for
identity makes him seem too often like a
brad at worst a boring also-ran of a
hero's journey protagonist at best when
you're not rolling your eyes at him
you're yawning and when it comes to TV a
yawn is arguably worse than a cringe
when someone mentions Quicksilver your
mind probably jumps to Evan Peters zippy
sarcastic portrayal in the x-men movies
watching him turn moments of terror into
high-speed slapstick performance is an
absolute delight something between a
ballet and a Marx Brothers spoof he's a
bright spot in an increasingly dark
franchise that no one anticipated a
total joy and surprise no then there's
this dude you didn't see that's coming
you might remember him from Avengers age
of Ultron on the other hand you might
now remember him at all it's not actor
Aaron taylor-johnson fault
really he couldn't have known he'd end
up compared to Evan Peters unexpectedly
brilliant take on the character but the
fact is that his betrayal of Pietro
Maximoff is well unremarkable he has the
right moves of course and his tragic
death is well tragic but there's a
reason Wanda his sister who has remained
a part of the MCU never seems to bring
him up no one cares Taylor Johnson did
his job and nothing more he ran he
quipped he died in a movie that
contained James Spader Scarlett
Johansson and Robert Downey jr. you
can't exactly rake the dude over the
coals for falling by the wayside Natalie
Portman is a talented versatile and
beloved actress that much we could all
agree on that said her MCU character
Jane Foster is one of the MCU s greatest
failures sure she gives it the old
college try in the first Thor movie
injecting foster with the charm
intelligence and excitement at the
prospect of wormholes and other
dimension
but even then her heart was clearly not
in it and by the time Thor the dark
world rolled around it was hard to deny
that she had checked out Jane just
doesn't seem very connected to the world
around her let alone the developments
happening within it and the performance
fades especially in comparison to any of
her other roles you can't win them all
but if you're Natalie Portman you can
take comfort in your Oscar and the fact
that you're basically a superhero
yourself believe it or not there was a
time when people laughed the idea of a
guardians of the galaxy movie we're glad
that time has passed but it's still
crazy to imagine that viewers have
gotten behind a talking raccoon a
sentient tree and a morally malleable
blue skinned space nanny rest in peace
brother
rest in peace anyway guardians of the
galaxy went on to become a huge hit and
a pillar of the modern MCU but as much
as we love star-lord and his merry band
of misfits we don't really care much for
the movies bad guy Ronan the accuser
it's no surprise why he's exceptionally
boring in a movie that is anything but
he's mad about space warfare that the
audience has no real stake in carries a
giant hammer wears dramatic eyeliner and
that's pretty much it when he showed up
again in Captain Marvel Marvel made sure
he was toting his hammer in every shot
lest we forget who he was and who could
blame us for doing so if we remember
Ronan for anything it's for being beaten
in a galactic dance-off look we're not
saying Ronan see on inducing
characterization his actor Lee paces
fault
in fact if Ronan's whole shtick is being
single-mindedly lawful evil and super
grouchy then pace has got this guy down
Pat's what we are saying is that pretty
much anybody in the pantheon of Marvel
baddies would have made a more
interesting villain than this dude Emil
Blonsky is an elite soldier who becomes
abomination the end point of the darkest
path Bruce Banner could take nothing
stops him from gobbling up power he has
no kindly girlfriend noble attitude or
passion for science he just wants to be
bigger better and burlier his fight
against the Hulk is a spectacular one in
which as banner goes on to sheepishly
recall in the Avengers they quote break
Harlem cool right
banner versus a grim reflection of
himself power against the looming
specter of corruption to giant man
beasts fighting to the death and yet
despite the memorable climax Tim Roth as
Blonsky simply fails to deliver one
wonders if had the stars aligned to make
this early effort more like the MCU we
know now all that potential could have
been actualized the way the Hulk
deserves but it wasn't Roth never got to
the core of his conflict with banner nor
the nature of his own evil he's just a
bad guy doing bad things for the sake of
it this gleeful one note evil can still
lead to great cinema but that is very
much not the case in the Incredible Hulk
Roth does what he has to do and
absolutely nothing more in humans was a
total flop for which Surinder Swann can
only be partially blamed nothing about
it worked the special effects were
cartoonish when they weren't outright
bizarre the translation of the Inhumans
fantastical world from page to screen
never rose above awkward and even the
best and most experienced members of the
cast seemed ill suited to their
characters it came and went without much
of a fuss few were excited for it few
saw it and few discuss it now that it's
done and dusted it was to put it simply
a failure so no it's not entirely swans
fault but if there is one person who
embodies the slow-motion implosion that
was in humans it is her part of it is
her costuming her wig is atrocious on
every level from its oddly stiff motions
to its Ronald McDonald shade of red some
of it is the absurd situations the
writers placed her in but most of it is
the maudlin melodrama she brings to her
scenes there is no amount of Inhumans
that more perfectly symbolizes the
project's sheer stupidity than watching
Swann deliver a drawn-out feral cat in
the alleyway yowl as her hair is shorn
by the fiendish Maximus it's meant to be
a moment of cruelty but it's straight-up
hilarious to watch her crumble at the
touch of a decidedly unfair of electric
Clippers nothing can stop the Inhumans
apparently except a hasty haircuts check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you